you you can't incentivize an effect you
can only incentivize the cause that
would hopefully yield that effect which
is behavior so if I say to you I will
give you a massive bonus if you hit a
certain target at the end of the year no
matter what what you're incentivizing is
that I will do certain things to achieve
that goal that you set for me
but the problem is is when we apply
excessive amounts of pressure and it's
at all costs like my very livelihood
depends on that it can accidentally
incentivize some quite unseemly
behaviors like hoarding information
right because this is what gives me my
value and I don't want to share
information or things that I've learned
with my colleagues and co-workers which
is madness or unethical behavior
stabbing other people in the back and
this is one of the problems with I think
our modern business today which is too
much of businesses is run right now with
an excessive amount of finite thinking
now there are always finite games within
the infinite game the infinite game
however provides the context and without
that infinite mindset all you have is
win win win win win win win which is
unsustainable
[Music]